so you're new to Google cloud platform
maybe you would like to simply check out
GCPs brett deploy some application of
yours or learn about google clouds big
data and machine learning capabilities
in any case welcome let me show you
around so first things first cloud a
google comm is your starting point this
is where you will find all the product
information and documentation but also
details solutions with architectures and
code with many different use cases
pricing is also detailed there including
Google's pricing principles and a detail
of cost calculator for every GCP product
and service cloud google.com is also the
place to access support to read customer
stories to find partners and to
understand how Google cloud platform is
different from other public clouds the
Google Cloud console is where you will
likely spend a fair amount of time
exploring and using the platform this is
where you configure billing accounts
create and manage projects and manage
all your GCB resources regardless of
their data center location every product
and every service has its own section in
the console left-hand menu with
dashboards detailed configurations and
settings you will also find interactive
QuickStart experiences from right inside
the console take this example QuickStart
for compute engine simply walk through
the various steps of the tutorial and
within minutes you'll be running a
nodejs application with its back-end on
compute engine virtual machines the
cloud console also offers a marketplace
with ready to go software stacks to
accelerate development so you spend less
time installing and more time developing
this allows you to deploy production
grade solutions in a few clicks with a
single bill for all your GCP and
third-party costs and it also offers
direct access to partner support to make
sure you setup your employees up with
the right permissions to use different
çb resources clock console also
integrates Identity and Access
Management or cloud iam and provides a
unified view into security policy across
your entire organization this is also
where you would manage quotas across the
platform every product comes with one or
more usage limits across the platforms
so you can prevent one team from
spending the entire Oryx budget on a
rogue query or compute job if you'd like
you may even use our iOS and Android
mobile apps to monitor and manage your
GCP applications on the go finally one
can sign up for affordable support for
both development and production phases
right from the console let's roll based
support enables configuration on a per
user basis and case management is
integrated into cloud console while the
console is powerful and flexible you can
do everything from the command line for
every action in the console there is a
g-cloud equivalent g-cloud is our
scriptable and almighty CLI and it comes
with the Google Cloud SDK Kyle shell is
a shell environment hosted on Google
cloud platform from managing your
projects and resources it is accessible
from a simple web browser and is powered
by a small virtual machine with
persistent disk and up-to-date software
for all your development needs it even
comes with a web code editor if you'd
like to know more about developer tools
check out the video linked in the
description below before you can use GCP
cloud console you will need a Google
account you can create a new Google
account or use an existing one such as
your Gmail account we recommend that you
enable billing for your project and that
you sign up for a free trial if you do
not enable billing you will not be able
to use GCP products beyond their free
tier if you do not sign up for the free
trial or if you're not eligible you can
still benefit from that GC be generous
always free tier you will find more
details about free
here and free trial in an upcoming video
once logged into the GCP console I would
recommend that you check out the main
menu and in particular the getting
started section start with a short
toward the platform tutorial in a few
minutes you will get a good sense of how
to get the best out of cloud console
next scroll to interactive tutorials and
take a short hands-on lab for the topic
of your choice without leaving the
console finally check out the main
categories of products eg has to offer
compute storage networking stack driver
for everything DevOps tools Big Data and
artificial intelligence as you progress
through your discovery of GCP keep in
mind those key resources documentation
in-depth tutorials support training and
free code labs GCP can be overwhelming
at first but with the small guidance we
hope that you are now confident that
your best ideas can come to life in the
cloud we're certainly excited to see
what you build and look forward to your
feedback if you liked this video please
like subscribe comment share and look
forward to more GCP essentials videos
[Music]
you